it's pretty bizarre how twitter is okay
with taliban thugs posting sick
propaganda on the platform while at the
same time censoring many conservative
american voices like the former
president now in fairness to big tech
the other giants facebook youtube tick
tock they do prohibit the taliban terror
group from using their sites but twitter
says the stone age taliban brutes are
free to tweet as long as they follow the
rules and are not too violent
well jesse i have to say that uh i have
a mere 330 000 followers that's it i
that's it i've like it's like nothing
zibi hula mahja hadid
of the of the taliban has three hundred
and ten thousand pounds
ladies and gentlemen i am begging you i
am urging you
at geraldo rivera don't let this taliban
thug beat me up so but i mean it does it
does smack of
bias
against trump particularly it does it so
stalin if this had been in the age of
twitter would have after killing 25
million people would have been able to
be on twitter as long as he didn't
violate twitter's terms of service
because that's what's twitter saying the
atrocities have already been documented
taliban cuts off women's fingers for
using nail polish they stone you to
death they kill homosexuals with cinder
blocks and then every friday evening
they bring everybody into a soccer
stadium and have the crowd watch people
get amputated and beheaded
so donald trump called don lemon dumb
but he didn't cut people's legs off in
front of a crowd not that you know of
not that i don't know what goes on in
mar-a-lago at night greg but i'm saying
that has not been documented it's worse
than watergate it is worse than
watergate
i just got if i can
uh my my paltry twitter uh are you
really in like uh general pissing
contest with the taliban twitter account
it's amazing how we even made this
segment
can i be your pr rep yes save that for
the next block
trust me on this but this is from
general john f campbell i i said save it
for the next block i'm running it i'll
go to you first
this is big big
news okay
again
in a sense everybody should have i don't
think that
big tech has the ability
particularly in the political sphere
degen to determine who is appropriate
and who is inappropriate twitter has the
ability and they're getting away with it
twitter has twitter has suffered nothing
by banning donald trump their stocks
actually up like 15 or 16 percent
year-to-date there has been there are no
consequences for twitter the bigger
question is if president trump former
decides to run for another term how did
they handle that but in terms of the
atrocities committed by the taliban if
you try to show photos of things that
the taliban has actually done to women
or the innocent on say instagram your
post gets deleted so i think that that's
supposed to be new
news but instead like a an airbrush like
just airbrushed asses all over the place
are okay but not actual
uh
photos of the horribles
of what these terrorists do granted but
dana i did receive a note from twitter
seriously
i
used the f word
in responding to something i really
didn't like
and as soon as i sent it i got a notice
back
are you sure you want to speak so
harshly have you read the whole note and
i said wow they really
trying to
help you protect your greg's thing
greg's thing about robots but i mean it
is amazing that their algorithms are
that sophisticated that they pop right
there i mean i do think i respect that
they're an american company but i also
feel like you are an american company
and this company is going to want
american protection from all the other
regulations that are coming from europe
um maybe not twitter initially but
certainly that's happening with google
and youtube and facebook and uh i think
that you could
rightly call it taliban twitter
and get away with it right so you could
like just figure out a way to do that
and the other social media companies
they have got they have a way to maybe
do that if they wanted to
press their competitive advantage but i
think to degen's point
one
it hasn't hurt twitter
at all twitter has hurt the world um but
two
i feel like the taliban will probably
get banned if they're true to their word
by probably like friday
you do i well because like when in terms
of atrocities
the islamic state used twitter uh as a
recruiting tool for a very long time
right posting just horrific images all
over it and they only stopped allowing
it when they got called out by the media
remember greg it's either me or
zabihullah mujahadeed in terms of
followers definitely start following
geraldo also when he leaves the building
we don't know what he's up to
i think uh taliban's probably
disappointed there's no beheading option
you can like and you can retweet
this behavior yes yes exactly um the
twitter is as consistent as trey gowdy's
hair right there
you can rely however that their
disciplinary procedures will only go one
way they mirror the people that they go
they discipline the people the media
hates and they protect those that the
media favors the washington post mark
this name mark siebel supports taliban
being on twitter as opposed to trump
because they follow the rules you can
slaughter women you can cut up their
fingers do what you want you can force
them to marry fighters but as long as
you follow the rules does that sound
familiar this is what the modern the
modern progressive has become it's about
words
but it's also about following orders
their orders their orders it's not about
law it's about orders and americans will
follow the law but we don't really like
orders that much but the other thing too
is it is it is kind of strange
and hilarious that the taliban is on
twitter period they want to return to
the dark ages as long as they have their
cell phones their ar-15s they're good
wi-fi maybe it's me but it seems like
cheating they're not really living the
life of fred flintstone which is what
they should be doing but i i really have
a
secret tiny shred of optimism that the
taliban does want to be part of the
family of nations that they do want
international aid that they will give
reasonable access to the airport by the
end of the month i i i wish i felt that
way but i feel like they only respond to
people who will crush them and that's
why they
we didn't have that as an option when we
were leaving but they're like they're
going to work with china why because
they know that china will continue i
wish them to china i hope china embraces
them well they raise the uyghurs
right well
it's related uyghur is muslim
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else